the world is visiting Berlin at the ITB
the travel trade show some 10,000
exhibitors from 180 countries are
presenting the most beautiful holiday
destinations in the world but how fit
are the travel experts really that's
exactly what I want to know can I find
someone who knows seven european
landmarks and also knows the city where
they are located I've got 15 minutes for
this so here we go ah bullen
brandenburger did that's right and this
france paris eiffel tower Rome the
Coliseum uh nother kingdomlondon the
London Bridge sits in Berlin and it's
beloften bug ya Lots London Branca Rita
the North Dakota like this pros Oh mr.
Elton German actual in Dublin it's in
Paris okay it's an evil tower maybe it's
in roma new tele right and i know the
call it actually is half-time in so far
i didn't find one single travel expert
who can name all seven european
landmarks that's impossible so I'll have
to hurry ah this is the the most
historic brand burger gauge in building
this is a penis Eiffel Tower Rome ah I
just forgot the name this is in the room
i have is GT times brandenburger gate in
berlin lottery fella Paris this is in
Rome Coliseum in london bridge Tower
Bridge Atomium atomium in in Brussels
this in in Greece in athen akola Polar's
in Copenhagen little marmora thank you
finally we got a winner and you get this
blue body bear from us it's a symbol
from Berlin
and it's also with a couple of landmarks
on it so congratulation see you bye I
didn't need 15 minutes so I won the
challenge but now I need holiday so
let's see what's on offer here